- I'm so excited.
Oh my God, you waited for me.
You waited for me to
sit down. You gentlemen.
- Thanks for having me
on your show, Kelly.
- Oh my God. Oh my God. Your accent. Okay.
You're so cute.
- Thank you.
- I love you.
I have loved you for so-
I think you're so talented.
And the coolest thing about
my job is getting to meet
like heroes, like musical hero as well.
But anyway, thank you
so much for helping us.
- Thank you, Kelly.
- Kick off the wheel of New York week.
- I'm so happy to be in front of people.
- You- I know, I know.
You spent a lot of time here though,
you've actually lived here right?
- Yeah.
- At one point? Yeah, yeah.
- Yes. A while ago.
- A while ago. Okay.
But when you lived here did you love it?
- And it led to a divorce.
- (chuckles) Yes it-
happens to the best of us.
- No, it was great of course.
The first time we ever came here
we came straight from the
airplane to Times Square.
And I'd never been to America before.
- Wow.
- I was like, wow.
America is just like the movies.
- Was it a letdown?
That, that was your first
experience times square
in the rest of the country? Did it-
- No, it was, it was just like landing in-
- Yeah.
- Back to the future.
- I know, what a great film.
- It was wonderful.
- Well, you have a, a guitar
here and I was just, just-
- I have about 55 guitars here.
- I know. I know. I'm like,
you're gonna play on 11, but wait
are you gonna play some Coldplay
and like maybe serenade me or them too?
Or (audience cheering and clapping)
Like, do you have a song that you're just
like feeling moved by right now? Like-
- Yeah, I have a song
that I'm feeling moved by
but it's not a Coldplay song.
- It's not a Coldplay song?
- But it's a Whitney Houston song.
- (gasps) I love Whitney.
- Yeah, well that's why I felt like-
- Which one?
- I've never been interviewed
by someone who's a better singer than me.
- Oh, you are? I'm done.
I've just achieved greatness. Okay.
So I have to ask, are
there any like covers
that you've done that have shocked people?
Like I've covered Eminem
which I shouldn't have,
but I did.
- Why? Why should you not have
- Well, you, you should see it but,
but I did it though
because fans ask on tour
for me to cover stuff and I just do it.
I'll just do it that day.
- Yeah.
- And sometimes it works out Chris
and sometimes it doesn't.
- Yeah we did some, we
did one the other day.
That was just really awful.
So I'm not gonna say what it
was, but it, we were trying
in this thing as a band and it just did.
I, I saw it back and I
was like, that just didn't
work at all.
Oh, then then a, a week ago.
So I, we played a Pony
by Ginuwine, which was
- (singing) Like, ride it my-
- Yeah. I could play that. Where is it?
- No, I'm- wait you should play that
You're about to play Ginuwine...
(guitar notes)
- Ride it my pony.
- Now this is the first song
that made Timberland famous.
You know.
- It's about to make this moment famous.
You covering-
(everyone laughs)
- But what's so wonderful
about music right now.
And this is why it's so great.
That BTS are so huge. Is that-
- Yeah.
- All of the boundaries and
barriers are breaking down.
You don't have to just be country.
You don't have to just be-
- Look, I've been preaching
this from he beginning.
- And that's how we feel about humans too.
So it's
- Yeah.
- So us playing pony to us just seems like
the most natural way of showing
that we like all people.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And all kinds of music, I was-
- And all countries everywhere.
- But you remember radio used to be
like that they would play
like everything from, you know
Sinatra to Hendrix to, it
would be like radio was just
they would play everything
they used to like when
it first started.
- Yeah.
- Now it's all segregated.
- Well that our job is to unsegregated.
- Let's do it.
- Yeah.
- Mission achieved.